背景の花かな日差しが身を包み
夏の日差しが我々の肌を照らし老化を促進させる季節となりました
トニージャー
はず社長です本日はなんとあの有名アプリ住んでごプロジェクトが本日はもちろんして
2周年ということでございますおめでとうございます僕ものんびりプレイしてやがても
1年以上経つかなぁもう1年以上もやってるんだね
1年以上もしれなくぷろじぇくんっていうんですけども
そんなにランクは上がっておりませんうんまぁ115g でなくきてるんでこれからも
よろしくお願いしますぅわけで今回はちょっと旬でプロジェクトにちなんだちょっと
スペシャルな事を知ってみようと思います白猫プロジェクト僕からしてなにがすごい
特徴的かと言いますそのゲーム性とかでいいんですね物語の面白さともあるんですけど
も一番はなんと
客さん入ってるキャラクターが全員とてもいいんですも新キャラ出るたびに僕は豊年
ドキドキしながら9月は回すわけでございますがまぁ何を隠そう僕のお気に入りの推し
キャラはシャーロットでございますわー
僕は今まで存在ですシャーロックをすべてを持っておりますこっちから普通の
シャルロットお正月るっと着馬
シャーロット全員持っておりますそして全員限界突破しております
トイレ今回私は3.が惜しいキャラなんですけども今回20年ということで私今回
シャーロットの等身大
となではいきません今回ですねあ
神への12キロパーク書士紙粘土ずに疲労が強くしました
こちらの仮面のずう2キロ分と太陽が貼り方準備したのでこちら組み合わせて12キロ
分のなんでコーディネーサンロット
できるだけ僕なりに2実に再現してちょっと作ってみようと思いますなぜ
肇社長12キロソロと作っ羽後
うざーの動画になること間違いやおサルの顔とか体つきでももう全部も1分とされて
ますからかなりクオリティーは高くなると思いますでは焼いていこう
愛情で作っていきましょう車両とこんな感じでございます職場でちゃうぞとですね
なんとがすげえことになってるなぁなんとは取ってあげましょう本当ねえシャーロット
藻岩山をちょっと語るよ見た目だね
サラそうなんですよねが子なんか色々言ってきそうな元気系の女の子とはなーと思っ
たら
ちょ宮ただけ何をするのも面倒くさくてなるべくこたつに入ってたいような女の子なん
ですよ
その逆でタモ材なのに強いんですよそう件に関してはここ最近強化が入りましたからね
もうこの総研の茶熊シャーロットニカチャ強いですよ
双剣強化が入っ
てまたこのシャーロットはね見直されたので僕はとても嬉しく感じておりますちょっと
愛をこめて頑張って作っていきましょう
1まず何をしなければいけないかというとサンロットの足組を作りましょう
に金で頑張ってとりあえず足の惨状作り出してある程度形でいつよ
脚の形ができればもう ok で
こんな感じです足骨組みなので適当でいたですここはこれで足が2本完成しました
こっからすね
足はだいぶぽくなってきましたねまずと甘いのでフレンジ台もうちょっとしてみ
ましょう
足はこんなものでいいのではないでしょうか次はひとまず
スカート店や胴体だ
涙のでちょっとバランスが悪いので背中に2本のパイプを入れましょう曲こういう感じ
です
エシャロット早計なんですよなんかからこの日本の刃はそのが総研になると思うので
見栄え的にそんなに悪くはならないはず
道は大体こんな感じでございます立たないんですけども文エンドを付けしないで少し
場所になればいいなと思っていますちょっとか見るとつけていきましょう
いい感じだでタッタッタッタ竜竜竜でバランスが取れるようになってきましたのでこれ
はちょっとプレずこんな状態で肉付けしていきます
できましたーーーこれ何て言えばいいのかなあまあとりあえずご覧くださいどうぞ
バッハ
あのまあわかりますよねどう見てもシャルロットっていうのはわかるのでまあひとまず
うまくいったじゃないですかね小学生の工作みたいなちょっと肌大サイズ的にはをいい
な
2分の1サイズ下でもシャーロットのふつうの家の自分の1のサイズでございますーに
家に飾っておきたいんだけどいい感じで紙粘土で車
ロッドを作れたのではないでしょうか僕のシャロー隊は伝わったと思います多分本当に
猫しに総研があるんですけどちょっと鉄5の関係でここがねぇなっつんだかちょっと
残念ですね
まるでバニーガールたいなかっただけでも作って楽しかったすも普通にパパ好きな
キャラクターだったね愛着がはてんだよ
自然と手が動いてしまいましたできで白猫プロジェクト自身で方
とにおめでとうございますキャラクター全員可愛いるってすごいコアいざが起こって
ゲームを楽しむことができますよくぜひ皆さんもそのべくプロジェクト
遊んでみてくださいじゃん
me
ん
4日